okay uh we're going to get going uh
going to open up the executive session
of the house election law committee for
House Bill
1370 um which is if I should read the
title relative to durable and
tamperproof Bot uh containers for
preserving ballots uh I will recognize
representative B for a motion I move all
OTP is there a second all second
representative Howard seconds is there
discussion on the bill representative HR
would like to speak thank you um
speaking with my city clerk's
office the first question is from him is
why would this be necessary cardboard
boxes are secured with tamper evident
tape along with the seal signed by the
ction officials accounting for the
documents enclosed within so with these
plastic boxes would they have the
ability to have that seal on them also
wouldn't that be gunking them up after a
few times that they're
used
um let the let the representative finish
speaking obviously you know we store the
cardboard boxes
unopened
and this would be a lot of room needed
for these plastic bins
containers um maybe they are prettier
but after a while they're going to get
ugly looking I think and we have 12
Wards in
Manchester I work the elections I know
how to package up a box and they don't
they're used over and over again we open
them during the day take ballots out and
then when they're cleaned out we put the
ballots in so they do have tape on them
but
um when we when the election is done we
have to pack them in a car
our 6,000 ballots going to fit into
boxes easy to travel over to our city
clerk's office to drop them off in these
containers I just I'm just worried about
this okay further discussion on the I'm
sorry representative I apologize
representative B is recognized yeah I
would like to answer some of the
questions I think the Box the plastic
one should be about the same size as the
boxes also as the Secretary State said
they'll be using a wire seal so don't
need the tape other than taping the
affidavit saying that they were suck so
I don't think it'd be that much more
room uh CU probably hopefully they'll
going to go for the same size of the
boxes and they'll last longer I mean
cardboard boxes don't last okay further
discussion on the bill representative
Hamlet you recognized thank you Mr chair
so I'm concerned because it seems like
we'd be using a whole lot of plastic
which is not good for the environment
the cardboard boxes are made basically
made out of paper they're recyclable I
don't think they're as bad for the
environment and when they're taped up
correctly with with the red you know
plastic tape that I think they're very
secure um yes they can get wet and can
get beaten up but I don't think there's
any there was no testimony given about
any ballots ever being
ruined so I think they're so I I think
the cardboard boxes are fine and they're
better for the environment thank you
representative how
recognized thank you Mr chair uh when
we're looking at the potential
destruction of ballots uh from potential
things like water damage I mean if we
end up losing those ballots then there's
no recourse that we can have to get
those back so we shouldn't be
necessarily risking uh something that
may be a one-off event uh if we can have
something that's reusable fairly cheap
uh and adds additional security thank
you further discussion seeing none I
apologize representative P O'Brien you I
just wanted to add about the uh tape I
that's a concern as well I can see what
representative hr's um uh other election
workers were concerned about who was it
that that was the clerk yeah the clerk
in Manchester but the the electronic
ballot counting machines are currently
sealed with the same kind of why
that um that representative bone was
talking about so there is that security
I had some questions about everything as
well that we can make the cardboard
boxes the same size as the ballots um
these kinds of things but I think it's
all going to even out in the wash okay I
think that in the end the uniformity of
the plastic ballots will will be fine
and I think that anything that can that
will um that will help with with the
perception that we're doing things that
in a much um more secure way fine let
it's it's worth it let's do it okay
further discussions seeing
none okay representative wood yeah I
didn't see you okay thank you thank you
m Mr chair um the when it comes to the
plastic containers we have to look at
the whole chain of events there's a
custody issues every time that box is
open and we know that these boxes get
open for multiple reasons recounts and
that type of thing the plastic security
is pretty standardly used in information
that needs to be preserve every time
that box is open there's a chain of
custody that needs to be filled out so
what happens is when you see any of the
results of these Audits and the
information that's brought to us you'll
see the tape is uh they use special
security tape they say void on it which
means whatever that seal is it isn't
accurate or holding to procedure there's
containers that can't stand up to the
weight of being stack which is a
security issue the the the I think if
you just put them in a box and never
touch them again I think the point is
there but these boxes have to be
designed to to be part of that chain of
custody uh uh and they can be opened up
multiple times uh by the people on the
list and every time they're open they
got to be signed off and every time they
returned they need to be seated
so if they get open three times we know
they were open three times by three
different individuals
so okay uh I'm going to go ahe and call
the vote um and uh the clerk will call
the
role uh representative B yes and this is
on aop pass uh representative Pome
O'Brien yes yes representative quae yes
representative Ankerberg is not not here
representative Burnham
yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne representative kutab yes
representative
Lane yes representative Ward no
representative HR no representative
Hamlet
yes representative
Mirad
no representative Bay no represent
Brennan representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter
yes is the chair would like to vote oh
uh chairman Barry chair votes the chair
votes yes and uh I don't know what the
count is because my brain in election
law is used to doing 10 or 20 so 15 to
four 15 to four I don't think we've ever
heard that with that it can't go on
consent uh representative HR will you be
in charge of the Minority Report um and
representative Howard would you like to
do the majority all right we'll have a
sorry no um I I no I I okay um who else
is on the bill it's fine who else is on
the
bill all right then representative wey
will write the majority report all right
with that uh thank you guys so much and
Tuesday